i just yeah i don't know i i hear
stories of you people living in like
dogs oh dude there was always one person
who was like the most
disgusting person like you you would you
would be made to believe by
by your mum that you're a [ __ ] slob
when you go to university oh yeah and
like you need to wash your dishes you
need to do this
but then you'd meet that one guy and you
don't know how he like functioned his
entire life
he would just we had this one guy in our
dorm who would just take everything take
all the utilities
and you know any like spare plate knives
and forks and he just like would leave
it in his room and just wouldn't wash it
so
we would often get times where we were
just looking for like i would be looking
for my plates and knives and forks
and i like had to ask him and one time i
remember looking for i think i think it
was like
a wine glass or something yeah and he
found it in his
underwear drawer and i was just like you
know what just just keep going
i don't want it anymore god how how do
you how do you even how does that even
end up in that underwear drawer that's
so disgusting yeah what the [ __ ] dude
i have so many horrible stories from
that like that period
and some of the [ __ ] they used to do to
each other like it wasn't even hazing
right it was just them being dicks
like right yeah like i remember they
didn't like this one guy in my dorm
because he was kind of pompous he was
like from south
england and he had a very posh accent
and he was very very like
oh you're you're too poor to talk to me
yeah immediately sounds like a wanker
yeah
he was he was like an [ __ ] right like
and and he would
like unironically call people peasants
like i call people
like is that how is that where you got
it from that's where i got it from
because i thought
i thought it was so funny that he called
people peasants and and he used to think
that like i was laughing at the people
he was laughing
but i used to find it so funny that
we're in the year 2000 and he's using
the word peasant as an insult
so he would call these rugby players to
their face like
peasants and he's not like big but they
knew they shouldn't punch him right yeah
so what they would do
multiple times was like piss on all of
his stuff
in the middle of the night and like
leave it outside yeah so they pissed in
all of his like uh kitchen stuff yeah
and so
he went to go and cook the next day
right and he was like where are my pans
connor and i'm like look outside
i told them they shouldn't do it but you
know what can i do
but i did not stop them i was like i'm
like oh no guys i was that dying
university who was like
not hated and not like be like in their
group but i was just like they liked me
enough where they would like tell me the
[ __ ] they were doing but yeah
yeah they wouldn't [ __ ] with you yeah
yeah they didn't [ __ ] with me um
they would always like meet in my
bedroom for talk it was weird
so they would piss on all this stuff
they got completely ruined and they
bullied the [ __ ] out of this kid it was
awful well i mean yeah
i don't blame them like [ __ ] okay if
a dude came up to me and was like hello
peasant i'd [ __ ] give him a hand
i mean like let's see how these peasant
hands feel [ __ ]
oh my god dude they were so they were
crazy man i can't believe this [ __ ] yeah
that
i hear stories like that i mean like i
hear from like people like you guys and
just
friends at uni who used to live in the
uni dorms and i'm just like why
why did you sign up for this [ __ ] like
it sounds it sounds horrible because it
sounded it sounds like when you're
moving into university it's like oh it's
it's a party
every day that sounds amazing and then
you realize
that people are just [ __ ] most of
the time yeah i just had like a
flashback to a horrible thing that
happened
what's going on so it was halloween
right and we had a little rivalry with
the
bungalow next door we were in bungalows
by the way right
rivalry with another bungalow that was
full of dudes what would you do to get
back at them like what would you do
like just send a message right
i don't know like whatever you're
thinking it's not as disgusting as what
they do
just tell us what you did yeah what did
you do so it was halloween and i was
outside having
a can of lager right i was watching them
do it and i was like i'm not gonna
be involved in this but i'm gonna watch
this yeah of course one of them decided
it would be a good idea to like take a
ship through their mailbox
right so they did that
and then they retaliated
by getting that [ __ ] putting it in a
halloween a pumpkin sorry
and throwing the pumpkin at one of my
friend's windows
and it just exploded it was so
disgusting so then they just thought
okay well they've this is all in the
same night by the way yeah
and again i'm just watching all this
unfold amazing entertainment
this is better than any anime i've ever
seen like cause
because they would like ask you is it
like i should do this i'm like that's a
great idea that's great yeah go for it
yeah fantastic guys yeah
then they're like watch this and then
one of the rugby guys like i'm gonna
like
smash their door in as a joke i'm like
that's an amazing joke yeah that's so
funny and so they smashed his door down
front door to their their like bungalow
they smashed it down
as a joke yeah like just destroying that
just destroy property
yeah it wasn't even theirs and then the
university obviously found out the next
day and was like
who did this and i and i was like i have
no idea
[Laughter]
and yeah they got they got so much does
it have to do with the poop on the
window they were like
why is there a pumpkin and [ __ ] involved
they're like literally monkeys just like
throwing [ __ ] around without my life
just flinging [ __ ] basically these guys
were like all in the rugby squad in in
like
the the biggest rivalry in wales and
rugby is like the big
imagine like i don't know which state is
like the biggest american football state
right yeah but imagine like the biggest
meat heads in america
yeah just in the same place like it's
like i mean we can just stop that in
sydney as well with rugby
yeah disgusting [ __ ] is gonna happen and
yeah yeah i guess because i was just
like
they liked me enough it wasn't hell for
me yeah i mean they would still use my
[ __ ] all the time it was really
important were you in like the really
cheap dorms
oh i was in the ones that cost 70 bucks
a month okay
i had like what would have been like a
psychiatric prisoner room
like it's like the bear but bear but
they gave us a mattress and i wish they
didn't
because i immediately when i got there i
pick up my mattress and it's
bright yellow the bottom of it and i'm
like oh god
and i remember i remember getting
homesick the first day i'm like mom i
can't do this
this is disgusting it was literally like
a tiny room
with a [ __ ] bed that they'd obviously
never change no
it was obviously like university dorms
are basically just remodeled prison
cells yeah yeah
like i think i'd rather go to jail
connections
i think i'd rather go to jail at that
point because the bed that they they
gave us
i remember thinking oh it's probably
going to be a single bed i didn't know
there was a size smaller than a single
guy
wait there is how do you hear that i
swear because it was way smaller than a
single one you you
you'd like to sleep like this
anything else and like my feet because
i'm like a fairly tall guy i'm not even
that tall
i'm six foot my feet was would always be
off the bed that's how small my bed was
just like three pillows stitched
together so there's your mattress
jesus christ yeah i'm glad i never
experienced that
i would just i would just bite the
bullet and just take the two-hour travel
between yeah my uni and my house and i'd
just be like
i'm in the comfort of my own i learned
some important life lessons university
though
right i learned like you gotta sometimes
you just gotta say [ __ ] everyone else
and put yourself first
sometimes i mean i i think i learned
that afterwards
people will just [ __ ] take advantage
of you oh yeah definitely yeah
like because there was only like one bus
that made it to
the campus on time like like it was like
half an hour bus
it's only one bus and uh this line would
be
[ __ ] huge to get on this bus so if
you were late it was just whatever yeah
and i got to the point where i was just
like i'm going to be so late for my
lecture if i wait in this line i would
literally just like when people were
getting on the bus i would just
walk to the front of the line just just
just just keep going i would literally
just like act as if i was on the bus i
would just walk up
bus and then everyone would look at me
like the [ __ ] we can you can do that
and i was like [ __ ] it i don't care
that's like that's like sacrilegious
in in english yeah that is that is like
a cardinal and i would never do that but
i thought because there were a bunch of
university students i'm like
[ __ ] you it's it's survival of the
fittest [ __ ]
we used to do that in high school where
like the because uh
do you guys have like middle school and
high school like seminary right now it's
all like seventh graders and twelfth
graders all together
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay so same in
australia and uh
you know every time like the school
finishes there'd always be like lines
for like different bus routes that would
like go in yeah yeah
and of course all the [ __ ] seventh
graders and eighth graders just like
get on they just [ __ ] start running
up and the 12th graders and the 11th
graders would just be like
out of the way [ __ ] the [ __ ] posted
these kids out of the way they couldn't
do anything but it was the most
liberating thing to do it was like
finally when i got to the 11th grade i
was like
i understand i have power now it's
[ __ ] awesome
learn the hierarchy yeah exactly step
down